Lors de ces conversations, elle m'a donné confiance
en me rappelant comme je suis proche de chacun d'entre eux,
et que j'en étais capable.
Je sais qu'il y aura beaucoup de moments
où je souhaiterais pouvoir prendre des décisions avec elle.
Nous étions toujours tellement en phase.
Puis-je avoir l'audace de vous suggérer
d'avoir ces conversations maintenant,
lorsque vous êtes en bonne santé.
Je vous en prie, n'attendez pas.
Dans le cadre de notre expérience,
nous avons organisé des groupes de visiteurs.
Quel courage de sa part de les recevoir, même lorsqu'elle avait commencé à faiblir.
Nous avons organisé une soirée
avec ses parents et ses trois frères et sœurs.
Les amis et la famille sont venus après.
Chacun a partagé des histoires émouvantes à propos d'Amy et moi.
Amy a eu un immense impact sur ses amis les plus proches.
Mais la fin de vie à domicile n'est pas si agréable
pour les membres de la famille qui lui survivent.
Je veux vous raconter quelque chose de personnel.
Encore aujourd'hui,
les souvenirs de ces dernières semaines me hantent.
Je me rappelle marcher à reculons jusqu'à la salle de bains,
soutenant Amy à chacun de ses pas.
Je me sentais si fort.
Je ne suis pas vraiment musclé,
mais mes bras semblaient si robustes comparés au corps frêle d'Amy.
Et ce corps a lâché dans notre maison.
Le 13 mars de l'année dernière,
ma femme est morte d'un cancer des ovaires dans notre lit.
J'ai porté son corps inerte
jusqu'en bas des escaliers,
à travers notre salle à manger
et notre salon
jusqu'à un brancard qui l'attendait
pour aller incinérer son corps.
Je n'oublierai jamais cette image.
Si vous connaissez quelqu'un qui a vécu cette expérience,
reconnaissez-le.
Dites que vous avez entendu quelqu'un
raconter combien ces souvenirs doivent être difficiles
et que vous êtes là si jamais ils veulent en parler.
Ils n'auront peut-être pas envie de parler,
mais c'est bien de tendre la main
à quelqu'un qui vit chaque jour avec ces images.
Ça paraît difficile à croire, mais on ne m'a jamais posé cette question.
L'essai d'Amy a fait de mon deuil une expérience très publique.
Beaucoup de lecteurs m'ont écrit des pensées très touchantes.
L'influence d'Amy était plus riche et plus profonde
que même nous et sa famille ne l'avions imaginé.
Certaines des réponses m'ont aidé lors de cet intense processus de deuil
grâce à leur humour,
comme cet e-mail d'une lectrice
qui avait lu l'article, déclarant :
« Je vous épouserai lorsque vous serez prêt —
(Rires)
pourvu que vous arrêtiez complètement de boire.
Je n'ai pas d'autres conditions.
Je promets de vous survivre.
Merci beaucoup. »
J'apprécie une bonne téquila,
mais ce n'est vraiment pas un problème pour moi.
Et pourtant, comment pouvais-je refuser cette demande ?
(Rires)
J'ai ri à travers mes larmes
lorsque j'ai lu ce mot d'un ami de la famille :
« Je me souviens des dîners de shabbat chez vous
et d'Amy m'apprenant à faire des croûtons avec du pain au maïs.
Il n'y avait qu'Amy pour voir la créativité dans un croûton. »
(Rires)
Le 27 juillet, quelques mois après la mort d'Amy,
mon père est décédé de complications
liées à une lutte de plusieurs décennies avec la maladie de Parkinson.
Je me suis demandé : combien de difficultés pouvons-nous supporter ?
Comment sommes-nous capables de vivre avec une perte aussi intense
et d'avancer malgré tout ?
Était-ce un test ?
Pourquoi ma famille et mes formidables enfants ?
Je suis désolé de vous dire que chercher des réponses est la mission d'une vie,
mais le secret de ma capacité à persévérer
est l'injonction très publique d'Amy
déclarant que je devais avancer.
C'est exactement ce que j'ai fait au cours de cette année.
Je me suis efforcé à sortir et à chercher la joie et la beauté
que cette vie est capable d'offrir.
Mais voici la réalité :
ces réunions de famille,
ces mariages et événements en l'honneur d'Amy,
aussi chaleureux soient-ils,
ont tous été très difficiles à supporter.
On me dit incroyable.
« Comment fais-tu pour t'en sortir aussi bien ? »
Ils disent : « Tu affrontes cette épreuve avec tant d'élégance. »
Devinez quoi ?
Je suis vraiment triste la plupart du temps.
Je suis en miettes,
et je sais que ces émotions sont communes à tous ceux qui ont perdu un conjoint,
un enfant, un parent
ou un autre membre de leur famille.
Dans le zen japonais, il existe un mot, « shoji »,
qui se traduit par « naître et mourir ».
Il n'y a aucune séparation entre la vie et la mort
si ce n'est une ligne qui les rejoint.
La naissance, ou les moments joyeux, merveilleux et vitaux de la vie,
et la mort, ces choses dont on veut se débarrasser,
doivent être affrontées de la même manière.
Je vis désormais une vie nouvelle
et je fais de mon mieux pour accepter ce concept
à mesure que j'avance dans mon deuil.
Les mois suivant la mort d'Amy,
j'étais pourtant certain que ce désespoir m'accompagnerait toujours,
qu'il me consumerait entièrement.
Peu après, j'ai eu la chance de recevoir un conseil encourageant.
Beaucoup de membres d'un club de veufs
m'ont contacté.
Une amie en particulier,
qui avait perdu son compagnon d'une vie, n'a cessé de répéter :
« Jason, tu trouveras la joie. »
Je ne savais même pas de quoi elle parlait.
Comment était-ce possible ?
Mais parce qu'Amy m'a donné, en public, l'autorisation
de trouver aussi mon bonheur,
je fais maintenant l'expérience de la joie de temps à autre.
Comme cette nuit passée à danser lors d'un concert de LCD Soundsystem,
ce voyage avec mon frère et meilleur ami,
cette virée avec un ami de fac
pour rendre visite à des types supers que je ne connaissais pas.
Remarquer le soleil qui cognait sur ma terrasse un jour d'hiver,
mettre le pied dehors et m'allonger là,
la chaleur envahissant mon corps.
La joie provient de mes trois magnifiques enfants.
Justin, mon fils,
m'avait envoyé une photo de lui avec un monsieur plus âgé
qui avait un avant-bras énorme, et cette légende :
« J'ai rencontré Popeye »,
un sourire énorme sur son visage.
(Rires)
Puis son frère, Miles, se rendant à la gare
pour son premier jour de travail après son diplôme,
qui s'est arrêté, m'a regardé et a demandé :
« Qu'est-ce que j'ai oublié ? »
Je l'ai immédiatement rassuré : « Tu es prêt à 100%. Tu vas y arriver. »
Et ma fille Paris,
marchant avec moi dans Battersea Park à Londres,
les feuilles entassées,
le soleil qui scintillait au petit matin, en route pour notre cours de yoga.
J'aimerais ajouter que la beauté est aussi là pour être découverte,
et je parle de la beauté du style wabi-sabi,
mais de la beauté néanmoins.
D'un côté, lorsque je vois quelque chose de ce genre, j'ai envie de dire :
« Amy, tu as vu ça ? Tu as entendu ça ?
C'est trop beau pour ne pas être partagé avec toi. »
D'un autre côté,
je vis maintenant ces moments
d'une façon tout à fait différente.
Il y a la beauté que je trouve dans la musique,
comme ce moment dans le nouvel album de Manchester Orchestra,
lorsque la chanson « The Alien »
cède parfaitement la place à « The Sunshine »,
ou la beauté envoûtante de « Killing Me » par Luke Sital-Singh,
lorsque le refrain dit :
« Et ça me tue que tu ne sois pas près de moi.
La vie est belle mais je me sens coupable. »
Il y a de la beauté dans les moments les plus simples de la vie,
une façon de voir ce monde qui faisait tant partie de l'ADN d'Amy,
comme lors de mon trajet du matin,
lorsque je regarde le soleil se refléter dans le lac Michigan,
ou lorsque je m'arrête et que je regarde vraiment la lumière du soleil
à différents moments de la journée
dans la maison que nous avons construite ensemble ;
même après une tempête ordinaire à Chicago,
lorsque je remarque la couche de neige fraîche
qui jonche tout le quartier ;
ou quand je jette un coup d'œil dans la chambre de ma fille
lorsqu'elle joue de la basse.
Je veux quand même préciser que je suis quelqu'un de très chanceux.
J'ai la famille la plus incroyable, qui m'aime et me soutient.
J'ai les moyens d'entreprendre un développement personnel
en cette période de deuil.
Mais que vous fassiez l'expérience d'un divorce,
de la perte d'un travail auquel vous avez tant donné,
de la perte soudaine d'un membre de votre famille
ou d'un décès lent et douloureux,
j'aimerais vous offrir
ce qu'on m'a donné :
une feuille blanche.
Que ferez-vous avec cet espace laissé délibérément vide,
avec votre nouveau départ ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)